Okay.
So we've been talking about
alkenes and they're polymerization.
And now we'll go onto
the triple bond analogs,
the settled liens for just a little bit,
and then onto a conjugated system,
starting with Al Alec,
intermediates, and then die jeans.
And then in general about linear and
cyclic conjugation and aero materiality.
So we can generalize from what
we know about Alkenes to uh,
settled liens. We have the same
kinds of reactions, additions of Hbr,
addition of water,
addition of h two.
But all of these have a little
bit of a different twist. A HBR,
we already mentioned this, but I'll go
over it again, the stepwise edition,
but Mark Kaufman to cough
the addition of water.
We see the possibility of Quito enal
to automatism and regio selection as in
alkenes. Uh, and then in h two,
there's a question of a stepwise edition,
one double bond,
and then the other one multiple
bond and than the other.
And the question of Stereo
selection. And finally, uh,
some stuff about acidity
and base catalyzed,
I saw memorization of a settled liens,
which you'll see are much more
acidic than alkenes are. Okay.
First we talked about this
already, but just to go over
it quickly, once again, uh,
it's possible to add HBR to a triple bond,
like one heck sign.
And you can use a catalyst that helps
make the HBR more acidic and you can get a
single addition to give the heck
scene to Bromo one heck scene.
And you often use an inhibitor so that
you don't get free radical addition of
Hbr.
Now we mentioned before it was a hundred
to a thousand times slower than the
comparable ionic addition to the alkene.
And the reason is the vinyl cad ion
is not so great at an intermediate.
And you can see that already in gas
phase ionization of the chlorides,
the one that gives the ethyl cad ion,
uh,
requires only 193 kilocalories
per mole to ionize the chloride.
But the,
uh,
vinyl compound to make the vinyl cat
ion requires another 32 kilocalories per
mole. It's hard to make the
vinyl cad. I am so that,
that's what of course you make when you
added the proton to the, to the, uh,
hexine. And it's possible to
isolate that in 40% yield,
which seems funny as we mentioned before
because if it's so if it's not very
reactive wouldn't the hexane you make be
even more reactive so that it would be
impossible to isolate something that
was part way along and the so you can go
further to to to dive Romo Hexane.
Uh,
obviously it's slower and it gives
a second Markovnikov addition.
Right,
which if the Bromo substituents slows the
addition to an alkene in order to make
it slower than the initial addition
to the already slow alcaide.
Why is the or orientation Mark Kaufman
the cough and we saw the resolution to
that riddle a few lectures ago that
the halogens do two things. They elect,
they withdraw electrons through the sigma
bond and therefore make it harder to
form the cad ion.
But if you formed the cad ion,
make it next to the halogen so that at
least you can profit from stabilizing the
unshared pair on the halogen.
Okay. We saw that before.
Now hydration and
hydrogenation of Al kinds.
First hydration, we can do the same kind
of thing. We did the before the ALC,
oxy mercury nation, which
you may remember, forums,
an unsymmetrical bridged ion,
then water can open it up
and you get the addition
of mercury in Oih,
hydroxy mercury or Asian.
Now remember what we did before when this
was an alkene to begin with and we had
a single bond in the product.
Nobody wants the mercury compound.
What do you do? What,
why did people make it?
Yeah,
the next step was reduction.
Remove the mercury and replace it
with age so that what you added was
effectively water.
Right?
So they used sodium borohydride
to do that. However,
it doesn't wait around for you to do
that under these conditions because you
have acid there.
And with the double bond,
it's possible for the acid
to, uh, to add to it now. Uh,
so you get that cat eye on
what's good about that cat I in?
Why is that easier to form than it
would have been if it had just been
irregular?
Alkene Lisa,
what does the o have to do with it?
Uh,
no. Well they're a double bond.
Gets farmed, rolled him lately.
But what's good about the cad ion
when you have the oxygen next door,
Brandon,
what do you say?
Yeah,
it has
unshared electrons in the P orbitals
that can be stabilized by the vacant p
orbital next door.
So that there's a resonance structure
that makes it unusually stable.
A Homo Lumo interaction.
But what leaves then is the mercury plus.
Okay,
so you get this compound,
which is an Ian Ole,
it's noticed that it was formed with
Markovnikov orientation as it would have
been the case if it started
with an alkene. Right.
But enols can undergo this same acid
catalyzed reaction to get that cat ion,
which is stable as we can see
in that resonance structure.
And what could that do?
Yeah,
well, who's a proton? Okay, so
it gives a key tone. This is,
this got traditionally the name
Quito, Ian, all Tao Tom Terrorism.
Tau Tau means equivalent to,
right.
So the idea was that the ketone and anal
inner inner converted so easily that it
was impossible to
isolate one or the other.
So that's a really easy alcoholic
rearrangement from one end of the,
from one alley lake
position. To the other. Okay.
And we talked about about the Keto enol
equilibrium last semester when we were
talking about bond strings. Just to remind
you, this is where we went through it,
added up the bonds and showed that the
ketone is much more stable than the Ian
all, I'll just flip through that. That's
just a, so when you're reviewing it,
you can look at it there.
Okay, so it goes to the ketone.
So the product from hydration
of the of an Al kind is not,
is a ketone. Okay, I'll Coxy mercury
ration of an Alpine. You don't,
doesn't wait around to do the
sodium borohydride reduction.
Now remember you could do the other thing
and an alkene add in the other Riggio
chemistry by using a boring,
for a settled liens,
you use a special Bahrain which has a VI.
What you get,
you get a vinyl,
boring is the product and it won't add a
second time if you have those are prime
groups sufficiently hindered so that
it's so that it blocks access. Okay.
Away you can do that is with a compound
called die. Same Old Boring, uh,
which is made with Bh
three and that alkane.
So you might think about
what the r groups are.
They are prime groups that you put on
there to make that hindered one with a
single age that an ad's only once.
So you get that vinyl boring.
And what do you remember
what you did with,
with boranes when we were added to a
double bond? What was the next thing?
Hydro duration.
And then what
incidentally, this reminds me that a week
from today is, uh, we have another exam,
right? And it'll cover at
today's and Wednesdays lectures.
I'll give a review
session Wednesday evening.
I'll tell you it probably eight to 10.
Uh,
and um, uh, so you have a
week to learn this stuff.
That's good news. Okay. Anyhow,
in the, it was hydro ball ration,
oxidation was the next thing.
Remember you treated it with hydrogen
peroxide and alk oxide to make the a
boring into an alcohol.
Right. And then, uh,
in this case we have a,
uh, an anal as above.
So that'll I summarize
to a carbonyl compound.
But notice it was anti Markovnikov
addition above was mark [inaudible] the
oxygen went to the more
substituted center. This one,
the trick you use when you do boring
the the o goes to the less substituted
center.
So in that case you get an Aldehyde.
So the h two on one carbon and the oh
on the other ad in one sense here and in
the opposite sense here.
So that's nice because if
you're a synthetic chemist
that gives you the control
of which product you want to get,
you can use one method to get the Markov
knockoff ketone and the other to get
the anti Markovnikov Aldehyde.
So this is hydration with either Riggio
specificity but also we could talk about
hydrogenation adding h two and here it's
a question of stereo specificity up at
the top there.
If we take a an alpine and reduce it
with h two and a catalyst as we talked
about with an Alkene,
uh,
you can get first this alkene
and you use a special catalyst.
This is called, was developed by a guy
named Lyndon lar and he added, led to the,
to the palladium catalyst. Led is a
poison for catalysts. You makes the,
it makes the catalyst less active.
Why might you want the
catalyst not to be very active,
Chris?
So it doesn't go all the way.
It'll do the acetylene but it won't do
the Alkene so you can stop and get it
there. If you use a more reactive
catalyst, you can go all the way. Okay,
so that deactivates the palladium and
stops at the alkene stage and notice the
two hydrogens came in from the same side,
so it's a sin addition.
For example,
you get a 97% of that sin addition.
If the are, is this ch two
taken three times ester group.
Okay.
Now on the other hand,
if he use sodium and ammonia a thing
called a dissolving metal reduction,
you get the opposite stereo specificity.
It's an anti edition right?
Now it might wonder that the sin
addition we talked about before,
it's the same thing in an alkene about
how the Palladian comes in and attack.
Then it gets replaced by one hydrogen and
buy another hydrogen always front side
attack so that it comes out to be sin.
That one won't surprise you.
But why does this one give Auntie?
Uh,
the key is that it's a dissolving
metal reduction. Incidentally,
in that case with and propyl groups,
it's an 80 to 90% yield of that anti
edition. And I think none of the sin.
Okay.
So it's a dissolving metal reduction.
So sodium actually dissolves in ammonia
to give electrons and sodium plus.
So it's a very interesting I and pair,
it's an electron and sodium ions.
Of course the electron is solved aided by,
by ammonias around and about it,
and it looks blue.
The solutions of electrons.
Okay. Now if you have an acetylene, an
electron will add to it. What? Orbital.
We'll go into what's,
what's the Lumo going to be?
[inaudible] what do you say?
Yeah,
high star. So notice it puts
in, there already is a, uh,
a pair of electrons in that
corresponding pi orbital.
So now you have three electrons
among those two p orbitals.
So you can write it as one being an an
I n with two electrons and the other
being a radical with the third electron.
Okay?
So we have an anti on
radical as an intermediate.
That of course is a very strong base,
the carbon and iron,
so it can react with the ammonia
and pull off a proton, right?
So we've added an electron and a proton
that's the equivalent of adding a
hydrogen atom, although it's
done as two stages. Okay,
so we get this a vinyl radical,
which is bent,
right?
Their sp squared hybridized
at that functional carbon,
but they invert easily in
the case of a radical right?
So it goes back and forth between the,
the RB on the same side
and the opposite side.
Now which one do you think is favored?
Obviously the one with the art groups
on the opposite side. So at equilibrium,
that's the one you have.
And now a second electron comes along
and goes into that singly occupied
orbital. So now you're going to
have a pair of electrons there.
We'll write the minus charge in
that sp squared, hybridized orbital,
but now it's harder to invert.
Remember x h three how he,
how if you added bore electrons, it
ceased to be plainer and became pyramidal.
The same idea here. So now it
doesn't flip back and forth rapidly.
Uh,
so a second proton can be
taken away from the ammonia.
Yeah.
And we get that product and the
two H's are on opposite sides.
It's an anti edition.
Why auntie?
It's because the,
that,
that isomerization of the radicals
favored the one with the RS far apart from
one another.
Then it got trapped as the anti on in
that geometry and then it went on to give
the anti product as we and gave
yields of on the previous slide.
Now the final special thing about Al
kinds that we're going to talk about is
their acidity and how that relates
to isomerization of Al kinds.
So we looked before at
these PKA values for,
for a carbon nitrogen,
oxygen in the order you
would expect them to be,
but that if you have an sp
squared hybridized carbon
or an sp hybridized carbon,
they get much more acidic.
Yeah.
We talked about this before, and in
some cases, if you have next door, uh,
if you're breaking a ch bond and next
door, there's a double bond you can get,
uh, you can get a extra acidity. Okay?
That stabilization. Okay. So
anyhow, we looked at those PKA is,
and here we can see, uh,
the energies of these, uh,
three isomers of an Alpine.
So you have the Alpine on the left.
The lowest energy is heavily substituted
on the far right is one that it's the
end of the chain. So not being,
uh, not having as many, uh,
carbon carbon bonds with
a special sp hybrid.
It's not as stable. And in the
middle we have the dying version,
the one to dying.
So at equilibrium,
you would strongly favor the,
the internal acetylene.
But how do you establish
and equilibrium among these,
you have to move hydrogens around.
So at equilibrium,
given those energies,
there's only 0.1% of the one to die
[inaudible] and 0.03% of the terminal
acetylene. So very little of those. Okay.
So we just talked about the
fact that that the Acetyl,
that the terminal acetylene could be,
or the internal acetylene could be
acidic because of the Pi bonds next door
making the anti and more stable.
So deed you could do that or you could,
you could do this one that was
on the previous slide as well.
Or You could do the terminal acetylene,
which is the easiest one to take off to
put the electrons in the low energy sp
hybrid orbital.
Now the PKA over here is 38 so that
means that the KIA is 10 to the minus 38
right?
Or the energy involved in getting up
there is about 51 kilocalories per mole.
Okay. Over on the right, it's
33 kilocalories per mole.
Still way up hill,
right?
So those energies are quite far above the,
we know this,
that's what we know from the pks.
So if we wanted to take off a proton
and then put it back on and take off a
different one, put it back on and
finally go to the final and ion,
we'd have to go way up and energy.
If you have to go up 51
kilocalories per mole,
that's not a very fast process.
The rate constant for that would be 10
to the 13th per second times 10 to the
minus 38 or the halftime would
be about 10 to the 17 years,
which is about 10 to the fourth times the
time that's elapsed since the big bang.
So don't wait around for
that one to happen. Okay?
So obviously you're not going to be able
to isomerize that way by just letting
it ionize off of Proton.
But if you put hydroxide in,
it reacts with the Proton to make water
and that's worth 21 kilocalories per
mole.
Remember the PKA is 16 uh,
four thirds of 16 is a is 21
so 21 kilocalories per mole.
So that makes it 21 kilocalories
easier to make the ani.
And because you're not making
proton, you're making water. Okay?
So that's going to lower these,
is that going to do the trick
to be able to isomerize?
Well now it's half time would be
about 30 years at room temperature.
Okay. But if you warmed it to 150
k it would be about two minutes.
So if you heat it up, you
could make the, the uh,
I saw memorization occur and then no
matter which of these you start with,
it's going to equilibrate.
And this is the lowest energy form.
And that's going to be everything except
there's going to be 0.1% here and 0.03%
there. Okay? So no matter which of these
you start with, you're going to get that.
However,
suppose you use a really
strong base like amid,
so now the, that favors a
loss of a proton. That is,
it'll take the proton by
45 kilocalories per mole.
So now we're going to lower those
ions even further like that.
And notice what happens on the far right.
It goes all the way down there.
And that's now the lowest energy forum.
If you have Nh two minus.
So instead of having it be all here,
which is what you're going to have in
any equilibrium among the neutral forms,
right? This is going to be
the lowest energy form, right?
So everything will be over there.
7.2 kilo calories down,
which means that at equilibrium you're
going to have only 0.01% of this stuff,
which was always the favorite stuff
before. So everything is now over here.
So the trick is now you
neutralize it very rapidly.
Right?
So the trick to obtain a
terminal acetylene remember
that an eye on is the one
that has the,
the anti and on the last carbon.
That's why it's such a stable
an ion cause it's sp hybridized.
So you equilla break with an amid base
in an amine solvent to form the terminal
an eye on.
Then you quench it by adding water to
donate a proton to the terminal and I and
and also to the R and, h. So
you have only hydroxide now,
which is too weak to allow
equilibration or if you want to,
you could just add acid so that you
don't even have, Ooh, they're all of,
that's gilding the lily.
You've already made it by not
having that really strong base.
So you stopped the equilibrium,
you'd put the Proton on the
terminal acetylene so you
could go from the internal,
the more stable when usually to the
terminal acetylene using this trick.
Okay. So that's all I wanted to
say about, about uh, settled liens.
And now we're going on for the next,
uh,
these two lectures and a
little bit probably still
beyond the exam to talk about
conjugation and Aram [inaudible].
So conjugated Pi Systems is
what you're talking about.
The name conjugated comes from an
interesting route that conjugated systems,
or when you have pi bonds
separated by a single,
a single bond and they're
called conjugated because
there are yoked together.
The word yoke is the same root.
It's a yolk comes from younger ray
from Yougo on which is to join,
right? So they're joined together.
They don't act independently.
We talked about this already in the first
exam and we may mentioned when you've
memorized functional groups and on the,
on the exam,
I had a thing that had both the carbon
eel and an amine and they were near one
another. But it's not a car video group
and an amine group. It's an amid group,
they are conjugated and they
behave in their own special way.
So now we're going to
talk about a conjugation.
So conjugation is where the
localized orbital picture, which is,
uh,
which remember we've talked so much about
pairwise to Adam's coming together to
give a bond and an anti bond or
isolate at the Tommy core bundles.
That was our intermediate between
hydrogen, like atomic orbitals,
which we really understood.
We had a table that we can draw
them out and the Computer Mos,
which looked very complicated, but in,
in between where these pairwise things,
right?
But sometimes we have to think more deeply
when these things are conjugated and
they don't behave that way. Okay. So
when does conjugation make a difference?
So first we're gonna look at experimental
evidence and then we're going to go
into the theory.
So a classic example
is Alec Stabilization.
Allie will comes from the word,
the same as I only or l and
French meeting garlic. There's a,
a sulfide in garlic, uh,
that, that has an owl,
a double bond than a carbon bumble bond,
single bond,
and then the functional
group assault side.
So that's an alcoholic sulfide
came from garlic, right?
So Allie ill is these three carbons
in a row, double bond, single bond.
So you can get special stabilization
when you have functional groups involved.
When you have a intermediates involved,
they're like the cat eye and intermediate.
So the energy for pulling off a chloride
for a primary and secondary are these
values in the gas phase? Of course,
very hard to separate the ions,
but if it's Alec, it's as good
as being secondary. Right?
So Al Lily because very good,
right?
Or if you look at anti and look at the
PKA of the Oah here at 16 we know if you
have a double bond here, falls by uh,
by six orders of magnitude, right?
And then the case where
it's an oxygen here,
it falls by another five
orders of magnitude than you
actually call it an acid.
Okay.
So the anti is getting much more stable
when they're out allelic by about eight
kilocalories per mole in the case
of the, of the eternal. Okay.
Or free radicals.
If you look at the bond energy
of a normal ch bond hundred one.
But if you make a double bond next
door so that this is Al Lilly, it's 89,
it's stabilized by about
13 kilocalories per mole.
So there's stabilization of these reactive
intermediates when their ally lake.
Okay. Now let's look at some
more detail about some of these.
Like the cat I an intermediate,
the addition of Hx to Butte to dying.
We talked about HX,
a halogen acids add into
single double bonds.
How about add into two double bonds.
Okay, so it might have 78 degrees.
You can add HBR to Buda dying and you
could imagine the h plus going on one of
the internal carbons to
generate that cat ion.
Or it could go on the terminal carbon,
the other Riggio chemistry and
generate that cat eye. And uh,
which of those do you think
is more likely to get,
which one would you prefer if
you were the proton I Asia,
the lower one. Why? First it's,
it's secondary and it's
also a little lake, right?
Which the first one isn't because from
this, from this carbon to the double bond,
there's an intervening saturated carbon,
right?
It's not two double bonds or two,
uh,
two sets of p orbital
separated by a single bond.
There's no overlap between this p
orbital and that p orbital. Okay?
So this was the second one is of course
also that because those are resonant
structures, but as I used to tells
us the top one doesn't look so good,
so we're going to get one of those.
But then in a second step we add bromide,
right?
If we do that at minus 78 degrees,
of course we generated the
bromide when we attack the Proton.
Uh, so, uh, we could imagine getting
those two forms by attacking this,
uh, this intermediate, this intermediate,
which is denoted by two resonance
structures. Uh, now in fact,
you get those in the
ratio, 80% to 20%. Um,
does that surprise you?
What would you expect for the,
for the ratio of these two here
you have a terminal double bond.
Here you have an internal double bond,
which one is more stable?
Do you like to have double bonds, more
substituted or less substituted? Arvin,
do you remember more substituted?
So this is backwards, right?
It's four to one in the wrong direction.
Now that means that if you
allow it to equilibrate,
it'll go the way our of and wants it to,
right?
But the initial product formed
it really low temperature.
It dry ice temperature
is backwards. Okay. Uh,
you can cause this, this in fact
can, can ionize to make the,
to make, go back to the cat I
and then come back and that,
that's a root for equilibration
between these two.
And you can encourage the bromide to
come off by putting ferric bromide if you
want to. It'll go faster. But at
any rate, that's the equilibrium.
So this is called kinetic
versus thermodynamic control.
So thermodynamic his equilibrium.
But kinetic is what you get first.
And those aren't necessarily the same.
It's this case we've seen before where
you start and you go up a certain rate
and then down to a product.
Or You could go to a more stable product.
Hammond would say you'd go faster
to the more stable product,
but sometimes remember it crosses and
it's easier to get to the, to the,
uh, to the less stable product.
And that's example here.
It's a kinetic controlled
under at low temperature. Now,
why,
when it's a question of rate
the first one to be formed.
Why do you think you formed the top one?
Anybody got a theory?
Yeah. How's it church? What
about the positive charge?
Right? It looks like this is a sec.
This is a secondary versus primary,
more of this.
So that's where at attacks,
that looks like a good explanation and
that's what you'll see in almost all
textbooks. So very good on a
rock. You can write a textbook.
Okay,
let's look at the,
let's look at the orbitals
that are involved in this
just for fun quickly. Okay,
so here's a top view down on the
four p orbitals of the [inaudible].
And here's the side view, right?
So here's the homo minus one.
That's the favorable combination
of those four p orbitals.
Okay.
And here's the homo.
That's the unfavorable combination.
It's Pi on this side, Pi on this
side, but unfavorable between them.
Okay?
That's the homo.
The Lumo has two nodes
among the four P orbitals.
And what do you think the
Lumo plus one looks like?
It's got three nodes. So you got
no nodes, one node, two nodes,
three nodes, okay. For combinations
among Lewis P orbitals.
Now the homo is the one you want to
attack with the, with the Proton.
Okay?
So where should you attack it?
Probably you get the best
overlap around in there, right?
Or You could look at how the, the, the uh,
potential on the surface that we've talked
about to see where the best place for
a proton is and it's in the orange region.
So that's,
that seems to more or less agree.
It's about there.
So that's where the Proton should
attack at the terminal, uh,
at the terminal carbon.
And then it would give the
pro penal cad I ion, right?
Which is shown here. There are three
hydrogens on this carbon here. Okay?
So that's the best product
then. Okay, now that's the,
the homo minus four.
It's a little bit silly to look at that,
but it's a ch bond that's hyper conjugated
a little bit with the [inaudible].
Now we have three P
orbitals here, here, here.
The one that was here became
part of this ch bond. Okay. Now.
How about the rest of them?
Okay,
here's the homo.
It's the pie.
Here's the Lumo one node.
And here's the Lumo plus one,
two nodes among those three p orbitals.
Okay, so that's the pro penal cad.
I am, uh, there's the Lumo that,
that you're going to want to attack
if you're the bromide, right?
So you could attack at either end,
not at the middle.
Okay.
And if you look at the
surface potential, uh, the,
the worst place for, uh, uh, a proton,
uh, uh, is where it's very blue here.
So that would be the best
place for bromide to come,
but it's in the plane of the ring.
It's not a place you can form a bond.
Okay?
Okay.
If you're willing,
if you want to come in from the
top where you can form a new bond,
it's a little bit green there and a
little bit blue, even better there.
So the blue place plus 144 would be the
best place to attack if you want to form
a bond, that's where bromide would
tend to be in order to attack.
So one would think that that this is
exactly what honor Rog has proposed,
right?
That it should attack there.
But here's a really interesting paper
that was published in 1979 where what's
being added to his,
not Buda dying,
but Penta dying another
methyl group on there.
So they add DCL,
which adds to the end to get the,
as one would expect to get the more
substituted Al Lilly [inaudible].
Right?
But now there's something interesting
about that that's symmetrical except for
the fact that there's a deuterium there,
right?
So if a bromide now comes in,
or in this case they use chloride,
it could attack either here or
here, right? If it attacks here,
you get the one, two edition
d and cl. If at attacks here,
you get one for edition d and CS.
Okay.
Now if it had to do with,
with the kind of thing
we talked about before,
where's the best place to put a chloride?
Where do you get the best overlap and
so on? That's the same here and here.
Right?
So it should be 50 50 in this case,
because of the intermediate
being symmetrical.
When it was beauty to die and we didn't
have this methyl group and it was
unsymmetrical and we did the analysis
of the previous slide where it would be
the best place to attack, but now it's
symmetrical. So we should get 50 50.
So here's the product distribution done
at a bunch of different solvents at
different temperatures.
And just look at a couple of these.
If you do it at room temperature
at 25 degrees, you get a,
you get a half.
Again,
as much of this as you do have this
more chloride ads here than here.
And if you do it at low temperature,
you'll get three times as
much addition here as here,
even though it's symmetrical.
So we've got to find some other
reason why when we do this,
the chloride tends to attack
here rather than here.
One,
two addition rather than one for addition.
Canadian buddy gets a reason for that.
Well,
let's look at the mechanism.
The first thing that happens is the,
we put a proton on and generate the,
this uh, cad ion and also
chloride. Now do you have an idea?
That's good.
Hi Alicia.
It's closer,
it has to move farther to get to one
four because this backside attack on the
hydrogen meant that the chloride has to
be out here someplace closer to this end
then to this end.
Right.
So it appears that rapid collapse of
this ion pair that you made before they
could I and could move independently and
established true symmetry that competes
so that the collapse competes with the
motion that would make a truly symmetric.
So it looks like it might
not have anything to do with
where the charges on the
surface or which resonance
structure is better. Right?
It's just where the chloride got formed,
ended at attacks really quickly when
the eye pair of collapses. So you had,
you could have written a textbook
but you might not have been. Right.
Okay. Now, uh,
Lle transition states also are unusually
stable and we actually mentioned this
before, but if you look at
the, uh, an sn one reaction,
so you're breaking away to
get a cat eye on, uh, the,
the relative rates are if you
take a hundred for t butyl,
which is very easy to form the t butyl
cat eye, and the secondary is, is, uh,
10 to the fourth times slower and
the primary just doesn't happen.
It's way slower than that. Okay. But
if it's how lily, then it's five,
five times faster than secondary,
even though you might think
it would be primary. Right?
And if it's Allah Lake with a methyl
group on it to make the cat eye and more
stable that you're forming, when
you break off chloride, it's, it's,
it's all half as fast as a
tertiary t butyl chloride.
If you put two methyl groups
there, it's, it's very much faster.
63 times faster than t butyl.
Right?
And if you put a methyl group here,
however, on this carbon that is,
so we've put a methyl group here,
it accelerates enormously.
If we put two Bethel groups there,
I really accelerates if we put
a methyl group here. However,
on the other end of the, or pardon me,
down in the middle w wait a second. No,
I, I had a, my game here,
sorry if we put it on the other
end is just as good. Okay.
But this is what I wanted to tell you.
If you put the methyl group in the middle,
it doesn't help at all.
So the methyl group has to be on one
end or the other of the cad I and you're
gonna make when you lose the chloride,
right? In order to get that acceleration,
if you put it in the middle, it doesn't
help. So again, we could look at the,
where the charge is in the cad ion and
you have to put the math for the methyl
to be effective and accelerating it in
an accelerated. The sn two reaction.
Sn One reaction. It has to be
where the charge is going to be.
Now how about sn two. Okay.
If we take the rate of of uh,
ethyl chloride to be one
reacted with f oxide,
it's 37 times faster.
If it's Alec at 97 times faster.
If you put a methyl lawn
and 560 times faster,
if you put two methyls on right,
if you put the methyl in the middle,
it, it, uh,
it doesn't help compared to the
compared to not have it in the methyl.
But if you put a Bethel at this end,
remember before when we were doing sn,
one forming the cat died.
We could put it either at this end or
this end and got the same right now it's
slower here. Any idea why it should
be slower in this case for the sn two
how about the rate of t butyl for sn?
Two
pft. Butyl three. Methyls
and you want to do sn two
very hindered, right? So this hinders
the approach because you're a member,
you're making a pentavalent
carbon in the transition state.
So Al Will Lake helps,
but this time you can get help from the
math at this end, but not at this end.
Okay. Now another. So we
looked at the alley cat ion,
we looked at the transition states and
Barb in form involved in forming the cad
ion and in the sn two process.
Now let's look at the alcoholic and ion.
And that's easy,
easily done by looking at the acidity.
So we have a PK of something like 52.
It's hard to measure for that,
but if you have, it's
alcoholic, it's 43 right?
And that's helped by a nine powers of
10 are about 11 kilocalories per mole of
stabilization for losing
that Proton at equilibrium.
And if you have a been a federal
ring there in what's called,
it's been Zelig and now it's even more
so about 16 kilocalories per mole.
So again, having these pie things
where they can overlap with the,
an eye on that's being
formed is a very favorable,
the order of 10 or 15
kilocalories per mole. Okay.
How about free radicals? Well,
here's a very interesting, uh,
these figures came out of this
paper by Ziegler. This Siegler is,
is not the Seigler who teaches Kevin to
20. This is the one who invented Ziegler,
not a polymerization. And that
became quite wealthy. Okay. So,
uh, so in 1942 working in
Germany at the Second World War,
he was studying this process,
he could get a 58% yield of,
of substitution.
This is this bro emanation
as a substitution pulling
off one of these hydrogens
and replacing it by bromide.
Okay, now heat for this purpose.
The paper that describes this
describes this particular calm, proud,
which is called [inaudible] sucks
and emod. Right? And in the,
in ether solve it in
30 minutes using light.
What is the fact that he was using light?
Suggest
that it might be a free
radical chain reaction, right?
He was able to get this 58% yield. Now
what's an brought, where does he get the,
and Bromo sucks. Inhibit. So
that compound is succinic acid.
Hey, he reacted it with
base to make the ad ion.
Does it surprise you that that ad I
could be formed with hydroxide? Remember,
and h has a pka of in the of
a 30 or something like that
and hydroxide is only a
16 at the PK of water.
How is it able to pull off that
Proton? What's good about that? And I,
and that we formed
Megan, do you have any idea can stabilize,
right? Yeah. To Carbondale.
Pi Stars to sets that stabilize the
high energy electrons are this nitrogen.
Okay. So you could make that out
iron, but it can, uh, that the PK,
incidentally that is 9.5
it's a very strong, uh,
acid as Nh bonds go.
And that could do an sn two
reaction on a br two to put,
brought me in on the nitrogen and
make the burrow, my dad and I,
and together with the sodium
ion that came from hydroxide.
So that's how he got NBS.
But you can take it apart again if you,
instead of using base use acid,
so if you,
if you use Hbr,
you can protonate this,
you could protonate that oxygen or they
could draw a resonance structure here
like that.
So it's easy to protonate here,
but now you can take the burl bide
and do an sn two reaction on the Br.
Right? So you generate
this now neutral, right,
which is an even or that easily I
saw him rises to back to the starting
material.
So base you could make this with
burl mead and if you add HBR,
you come back, right? And
of course also get br too.
That was what was formed here.
So you can get the br two back
again if you want to from NBS.
Now back to the reaction.
Uh,
we could imagine doing a reaction
of br two with a double bond.
What reaction have we talked about?
Br plus a double bond.
It's the addition electrophilic
addition to a double bond, right?
We talked about this a good deal.
No doubt it will be covered
on the exam next Monday. Okay,
you do this here at room
temperature in the dark.
You hit the bro Ammonium ion first.
Remember how we talked about that?
And then you get anti audition. Okay? Now,
but suppose you want to do substitution.
That's what Ziegler dead, right?
He didn't add bro mean to the double bond.
He replaced an aloe lake,
hydrogen with bromine.
So those substitutions are typically
free radical substitutions.
So you could have this same compound,
but I show the hydrogens,
because if you have ways to get a
free radical, like a bromine atom,
it can pull off. Get HBR.
I had this, but remember,
we use bromine here, not chlorine
because it's slow and selective.
So if you use chlorine, uh, it
also takes not only this hydrogen,
but also this hydrogen almost
this rapidly. It's not selective,
but bromine is selective.
It's uphill, okay?
Then you can react it with
br two and replace, uh,
where the hydrogen is with bromine.
So you've done alkylate Brahman nation,
and of course the, uh, uh, this,
this alcoholic intermediate
was resonant of this farm.
You could have put the bromine either
here or here. So you also get that,
which is the same material in the case
shown. But if you had a substituent,
it would be in a different position.
If you had something on
the ring substituted here,
it would be a different compound.
Okay? And it also gives a bromine atom.
Why is that relevant?
What happens to the bromine atom?
Math,
it gets reused. Theoretical
chain. It goes back.
Let's start. It's a chain reaction. Okay,
so how do you control what you're going
to get? Are you going to get bromine,
bromine edition or alcoholic substitution?
Right?
Can you think of any way of controlling
which of these you put bromine in?
Which of these things is going to operate?
Okay?
Is there a way any handle you have on it?
Matt can use photo initiation to get
the rat if you use notice this one? Yes,
it's done in the dark. Right? If we
don't, if we can't get the radical,
we won't do this one. Okay, so one,
I want ideas to keep it in the dark,
right? Don't use the initiator.
Okay. Now suppose we want,
so that'll allow us to do this one,
that dark one.
How do we get this one to happen?
Well,
you might say we use light
or using initiator, right?
But this can still happen.
If you have the light on,
you can still get that right.
It doesn't require dark.
It's just this one requires light.
Okay,
so this one would also be
going on but another way,
which is to minimize the
concentration of br too.
Now why does that have
anything to do with it?
This is a really interesting thing about
the kinetics of the top reaction, right?
It's second order in br too.
That looks really weird.
Why do you need two molecules
of bromine in order to do this?
Yeah.
The reason is that you want to make,
when you get the Br plus coming on,
br minus is coming off from br too.
So you have to get br minus and in fact
br minus is stabilized by reacting with
Vr too to give br three minus.
So in fact what happens is that the br,
the second VR two helps the bromide
leave from br plus in a non polar solvent
like this, right? So it's second
order. So that means if you,
if you have a really low concentration
of br to this one gets really slow
because it's a bad leaving
group, right? It's like make,
making the BR minus leave by putting
br two in is like making Ooh lead by
putting a proton on it. Make it a better
leaving group. Okay, so we want to,
if we minimize the concentration
of br two will slow this one down.
But that reaction with
VR too is very fast.
Remember the first step of
this is is endothermic is slow,
but that's step is really fast.
Okay.
So we can tolerate a low
concentration of br for this purpose.
But how are you going to do it?
Right?
Cause suppose you'd put in just a TD
about have just a teeny amount of br two
there. Okay. This starts in,
but quickly you've exhausted the br
two and now the radical chain stops.
Right? And that's the end of the
line right now you could say,
I'll just, I'll, I'll,
I'll very carefully run in
br to very slowly, right?
Just to balance out.
But when you put a drop in,
the bromine concentration is
higher in that drop locally, right?
So you're going to get this reaction
because of the local high concentration of
br too.
Right?
But this is where it Siegler comes
in with his clever NBS molecule.
This looks like it's tedious to
impossible to maintain a really low
concentration of br too,
while it's being consumed all the time.
But notice that this
reaction also yielded Hbr,
right?
Whenever that happens.
And if we have envy and Bravo
[inaudible] sucks in amid plus Hbr,
that's the reaction we looked at on the
previous slide that destroys and Bromo
sucks.
Cinnamint takes it back to succeed him it.
And remember what the other product was.
Okay.
B
R two.
So isn't this neat?
Whenever a br two bollock
tool gets used up,
a new br two molecule is
created by this reaction, right?
So it automatically maintains the
minimum possible concentration of br too.
Every time you use it,
you get a new one.
You don't have to sit there
with your bureaucrat trying
to run it in very slowly.
So that's the trick with an
Bromo sucks and emit now.
So we've looked here at a lot of
different Alec stabilizations, right?
But dining's can also be conjugated.
And how much is that worth?
Okay. We can look at the heat
of combustion of this one,
which where they're not conjugated,
and this one where there's
across across a single bond,
these isomers of one another,
and you can see that it's the
conjugation seems to be worth about seven
kilocalories per mole or down here it
seems to be worth about eight kilocalories
per mole. But these numbers, all of
their claimed to be very precise,
are big numbers,
right?
And that I think that precision might
be a little bit overstated, right?
If you look at the heat of hydrogenation,
that heat that's given off,
when you add h two then you can see that
these are all 30 I'm going to let you
go after you make two
guesses. Okay, now guess what?
It should eat this double bond.
The stove on this double bond,
they all give off 30
kilocalories per mole of heat.
How much should this one give off when
you hydrogenate both double bonds.
16 lean.
How about this one
now,
how about this one?
Something bigger.
So conjugation, this one is more stable.
It doesn't give off as much heat, right?
And it seems to be stable by about
four kilocalories per mole. Okay.
Now you can go.